en science quand une théorie est à la
fois simple et claire et quand elle fait
des prédictions plus juste que nous
importe quel autre théorie y compris
notre intuition
alors il faut faire davantage confiance
en la théorie en question plutôt qu'en
les autres théories que notre intuition
pourrait imaginer
et ce même si la théorie en question est
super contre intuitive et sur scène ce
vol on en a vu des théories contre
intuitive de la géométrie hyperbolique
ou le théorème de pythagore et fo au
principe d'équivalence d'einstein qui
dit que le sol accélère vers le haut en
passant par la logique intuition nist où
certains ensembles sont ni fini ni
infini
aujourd'hui ce dont on va parler c'est
de la meilleure théorie dont les
sciences dispose de la politique
cette théorie est si performante que le
professeur bruce bueno de mesquita c'est
appuyer dessus pour écrire un algorithme
qui prend en compte des données fournies
par des experts pour effectuer des
prédictions régulièrement acheter par
les pdg des grandes entreprises et les
agences de sécurité type est née ça de
façon stupéfiante
l'algorithme fait de meilleures
prédictions que les experts qui en ont
fourni l'étonné et ça ça montre bien que
le modèle de mesquita n'exploite pas des
données que les experts n'ont pas si le
modèle de la politique selon mesquita
est plus performant pour faire des
prédictions c'est uniquement parce que
sa logique et ses postulats sont plus
valides que la manière dont même les
experts pensent la politique ou dit
autrement le principe fondamental de la
politique selon mesquita et
scientifiquement beaucoup plus fiable
que ce que chacun d'entre nous pourrait
penser comprendre de la politique et ce
peu importe à quel point ce principe
fondamental et contre intuitif alors ce
principe fondamental c'est quoi et bien
pour le comprendre
je vous propose de parler de l'un des
personnages les plus mystérieux de
l'histoire de l'humanité
le roi léopold ii de belgique le bon
vieux roi léopold ii 2 de belgique
ouais mais tous y construit tellement de
trucs bg qu'on le surnomme le roi
bâtisseur
il met en place l'éducation gratuite
obligatoire autorise les ouvriers à se
réunir en syndicat
interdit le travail pour les enfants de
moins de 12 ans et instaure le vote au
suffrage universel
léopold ii est donc très certainement
l'un des meilleurs droits de l'histoire
les belges l'adorent sauf que pendant ce
temps léopold 2 était aussi le roi du
congo au congo ce fut un carnage
les militaires maltraité la population
et régner en maître absolu le bilan de
tout ça environ 10 millions de marks a
confirmé de soi autant voire plus que
durant l'holocauste quarante ans plus
tard oui vous l'avez bien compris le
meilleur roi de l'histoire de la
belgique est aussi l'auteur d'un
génocide comparable à l'extermination
des juifs par hitler pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale
comment un même individu peut-il avoir
été autant adulé et détesté comment une
même personne a pu être si
philanthropiques et criminel comment un
homme a pu être si bienfaiteurs et
démoniaque pour mesquita toutes ces
questions sont à côté de la plaque
selon son principe fondamental de la
politique un homme au pouvoir n'est ni
gentil ni méchant il n'est ni
bienveillant ni malveillants il n'est ni
charitable ni machiavélique pour
mesquita tout ce qu'un homme politique
souhaite c'est être et rester au pouvoir
qu'il soit mère teresa ou la tête
pensante d'une organisation terroristes
extrémistes
qu'il soit le dictateur d'un régime
autoritaire où le président d'une
république démocratique qu'il soit le
chef d'une institution publique ou le
pdg d'une firme multinationale les
désirs conviction religions cultures et
volonté de ces individus importe peu ce
qui importe c'est accéder au pouvoir et
y rester durablement
tel est le principe fondamental de la
politique sommet ce qui t'a et ce n'est
pas le politicien guy manly interviewé
par john oliver qui contredira ce
principe fondamental
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi donc pourquoi les hommes
politiques sera utile si obsédé par le
pouvoir
est ce parce que les hommes politiques
ont tous suivi le même conditionnement
je veux dire la même éducation
ça joue sans doute mais il ya une
explication beaucoup plus simple la
politique est un jeu entre politiciens
et les politiciens qui passent beaucoup
de temps à étudier les sciences pour
ensuite améliorer les conditions de vie
du peuple ont plusieurs longueurs de
retard sur ceux qui veulent juste gagner
au game of thrones
quand le trône attise la convoitise la
compétition est rude et les politiciens
qui accèderont et resteront pouvoir
seront ceux qui ont fait ce qu'il
fallait pour y accéder et qui font ce
qu'il faut pour y rester telle est le
grand jeu de la politique
et si le roi léopold ii a marqué
l'histoire en restant au pouvoir aussi
longtemps en belgique et au congo c'est
parce qu'il avait parfaitement compris
les règles du jeu de la politique au
congo les forces militaires était une
source de pouvoir majeur pour ne pas se
faire renverser par ses forces armées
le roi léopold ii devait instituer un
système qui les enrichit par chance pour
léopold le congo dispose est d'une
richesse naturelle le caoutchouc
à une époque où l'industrie des
bicyclettes et des voitures était en
train d'émerger grâce à cette matière
première
léopold ii savait que récolter ce cas où
tu le rend très riche
l'argent du caoutchouc pourrait ensuite
être partiellement redistribuer à ses
généraux militaires ce qui les
satisferait et leur donnerait une bonne
raison de ne pas tenter de coup d'état
mais pour assurer un flot permanent de
richesses pour ses généraux léopold
devait forcer son peuple à exploiter les
ressources naturelles de leur pays et
s'assurer que ce peuple reverserait la
quasi totalité de ses ressources à
léopold lui même
pour garantir la taxation quasi totale
de son peuple
léopold se devait d'être dur avec lui
ils devaient encourager les militaires à
exterminer tous ceux qui pourraient être
réfractaire à la taxation drastique de
léopold deux pour être et rester au
pouvoir
léopold devait violemment oppressé
torturé et exterminer le peuple
congolais et leopold a violemment
oppressé torturé et exterminer le peuple
congolais au congo leopold flins des
rois les plus criminels et de plus
meurtrier de l'histoire mais en belgique
en belgique la démocratisation des
technologies et de la richesse a remis
en question son autorité pour rester au
pouvoir
léopold deux se devait d'anticiper
l'émancipation inéluctable de son peuple
il lui cv ainsi du pouvoir avant que
celui ci ne le renverse
mieux encore à une époque où des
industries lourdes naissante nécessité
des travailleurs qualifiés la majeure
partie de la richesse du pays s'étaient
transférer des ressources naturelles au
capital humain pour produire plus pour
produire mieux et pour avoir plus de
richesses à redistribuer aux autres
individus institutions gouvernants la
belgique
léopold deux avaient tout intérêt à
investir dans le capital humain
ils avaient tout intérêt à investir dans
une éducation gratuite et obligatoire
pour tous les enfants belgique ils
avaient tout intérêt à autoriser les
ouvriers des entreprises à se réunir en
syndicats pour éviter toute émeute de
leur part il avait même intérêt à
instaurer un vote au suffrage universel
parce que des citoyens plus éduqués plus
organisés et plus impliqué politiquement
étaient des citoyens plus entreprenants
plus productifs et produisant plus de
richesses que léopold pourra réinvestir
dans des biens publics pour davantage
gagner le coeur de ceux qui gouvernent
et les amener à le préférer à de
potentiels président ministre élu pour
gouverner la belgique à sa place pour
être et rester au pouvoir
léopold avait tout intérêt à améliorer
les conditions de vie de son peuple
belge léopold à améliorer les conditions
de vie de son peuple belge
un homme politique n'est pas bon ou
mauvais un homme politique analyse
toutes ces options est choisie celle qui
maximise ses chances d'être et de rester
au pouvoir
du coup ce qui fait que l'homme
politique fera quelque chose de bon ou
de mauvais n'est pas l'homme politique
lui-même ce qui fait qu'un homme
politique fera quelque chose de bon ou
mauvais ce sont les incitatifs ou
incentives qui lui sont données en
particulier si la richesse d'un pays
dépend essentiellement de l'exploitation
d'une ressource naturelle
alors les dirigeants de ce pays auprès
seront deux peuples et ce ne sera pas
alors parce que les hommes au pouvoir
sont des psychopathes corrompu par le
pouvoir ce sera parce que pour ne pas se
faire renverser par leurs rivaux les
hommes au pouvoir devront agir en
dictateur autoritaire et devront
oppressé leur peuple si c'est en faisant
le mal qu un homme politique pourra être
et rester au pouvoir alors il fera le
mal mais à l inverse ci étant donné le
contexte socio-économique et les
positions idéologiques de ses supporters
un homme politique devra faire le bien
pour être reste le pouvoir alors il fera
le bien tel est le principe fondamental
de la politique se met ce qui t'a tout
homme politique peut être et rester au
pouvoir et je le répète ce principe
fondamental est au fondement de la
meilleure théorie scientifique que l'on
a de la politique et les prédictions de
cette théorie sont plus juste que les
prédictions des experts
elles seront donc aussi forcément
beaucoup plus fiable que chacun de mes
avis personnel et que chacun de vos avis
en bon scientifique il nous faut
préférer penser selon la logique de ce
modèle de la politique plutôt que selon
notre intuition nos avis et ça ça veut
dire qu en particulier il faut prendre
très au sérieux
les conséquences très contre intuitive
de ce principe fondamental de la
politique numéro un ce que les hommes
politiques pensent vraiment importe peu
c'est pour ça que je sens sur vos
messages sur les hommes politiques
certes les hommes politiques diffèrent
dans les réseaux d'influencé qu'ils
possèdent et subissent et dans leur
capacité à convaincre d'autres à se
rallier à leur cause
mais ce qu'il pense vraiment n'importe
pas ce qui importe ce sont les autres
politiciens les lobbys et les électeurs
envers lesquels ils sont redevables et
sans lesquels ils ne pourront pas être
et rester au pouvoir
numéro 2 les concepts de mérite et de
responsabilité des hommes politiques
sont inutiles pour analyser comprendre
et prédire la politique
les hommes politiques ne réagissent pas
à la responsabilité ou au mérite
ils réagissent uniquement aux incentive
c'est à dire à ceux qui pourraient
remettre en cause leur stratégie pour
être et rester au pouvoir
ça veut pas dire que ça sert à rien de
critiquer leurs positions idéologiques
après tout notamment en démocratie si le
peuple menace le pouvoir d'un homme
politique parce qu'il dit de lui qui ne
mérite pas son poste ou qu'il est
irresponsable
alors pour être et rester au pouvoir
l'homme politique en question pourraient
avoir intérêt à davantage suivre l'avis
du peuple plutôt que celui des lobbys
mais du coup ce qui importe là c'est
davantage la perception du mérite et de
la responsabilité des hommes politiques
selon le peuple est en tout cas ce n'est
pas la perception du mérite et de la
responsabilité
selon les politiciens ni d'ailleurs
selon moi numéro 3 les hommes politiques
ne sont pas stupides
s'il était stupide il aurait perdu au
jeu de la politique et on n'aurait
jamais entendu parler d'eux bien entendu
ils ne sont pas en mission non plus
après tout le modèle de la politique
sont mesquita surpasse les capacités
cognitives de même les experts de la
politique et nécessitent des calculs par
ordinateur mais ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que les politiciens sont bien
plus malin que ce qu'on dit si souvent
d'eux si on en vient à croire qu'ils
sont stupides c'est parce que l'on en a
une vision exagérée stigmatiser
caricaturé et parce que l'on comprend
mal les incentives qui leur sont
imposées et ce n'est pas surprenant que
l'on comprend mal leur incentive après
tout il arrive souvent qu'ils soient
dans l'intérêt des hommes politiques de
garder secrets et confidentiels
les alliances politiques qui les lie à
d'autres hommes politiques ou à d'autres
organismes numéro 4 avoir raison ne sert
à rien en politique il me semble que
trop souvent quand on parle de politique
on se demande qui a raison et avoir
raison les hommes politiques s'en moque
complètement
ce n'est pas en ayant raison qu'ils
accéderont au pouvoir et resteront ce
qui importe pour le politicien c'est que
les autres hommes politiques les
partenaires industriels et l'électorat
leur donne raison et ça c'est vraiment
pas la même chose pour gagner une
élection
les politiciens ont bien plus intérêt à
concevoir diffusé et défendre des
convictions semblable à celle des autres
appareils dans l'épisode précédent qu'a
se fonder sur des données empiriques et
des théories axiomatique numéro 5
avant de vous lancer en politique pour
changer le monde réfléchit saisir à deux
fois
certes sans pouvoir vous pourrez rien
changé mais l'accession au pouvoir
exigera certainement de vous que vous
abandonniez certaines de vos convictions
non pas parce que vos idées sont
mauvaises mais parce qu'il ya de bonnes
chances que les autres politiciens les
personnes d'influencé et l'électorat ne
vous donne pas raison en particulier les
politiciens n'ont pas besoin d'idées
nouvelles
les politiciens ont besoin d'idées qui
plaisent aux autres politiciens aux
personnes -des influence et à
l'électorat
numéro 6 quand vous irez voter dimanche
ne vous demandez pas pour qui vous
voulez voter demandez vous plutôt quels
sont les incentives que vous voulez
imposer au futur président de la
république
demandez vous si pour être et rester au
pouvoir l'homme politique en question
aura intérêt à appliquer le programme
qu'il a promis et s'il ya des choses qui
n'a pas promis de fermer qu'il aura
intérêt à faire une fois au pouvoir en
particulier ne votez pas pour des
personnes ne votez pas pour des valeurs
non plus ne votez pas pour des idées
voter pour les incentives qui
incomberont notre prochain président de
la république
l'anr fin on a parlé des convictions et
diana de 0 01 cent qui avait une
influence de sidi pigrée dans la vidéo
précédente
tout à fait en fait le fond de la vidéo
précédente et ultra inspiré de la vidéo
dix vidéos une mutuelle oui et la forme
et était aussi largement inspiré de vous
pour vous l'os qui est la vidéo de ce
type y qui parle de brousse bruno des
mesquida
je recommande ultra vivement cette vidéo
pour moi la politique n'a de sens que si
l'on réfléchit dans des modèles à la
mesquita et c'est ce que présente très
bien ses équipes y vraiment cette vidéo
je vous conseille vraiment de l'avoir de
la revoir et de l'art revoir
personnellement j'ai dû avoir dizaine de
fois et j'ai l'impression qu'à chaque
fois que je la regarde j'apprends encore
un petit peu mieux à penser selon la
logique du modèle de mes skis car
nicolas larocque qui semble avoir
apprécié le fond de la vidéo précédente
mais critiquent la forme et vu le nombre
de like cas ce commentaire je pense
qu'il ya pas mal parmi vous qui ont été
mal à l'aise vis-à-vis du thon de
musique que j'ai employé dans la vidéo
précédente
si vous n'avez pas aimé bas je m'en
excuse l'export aussi de différents
styles
tu dois bien dire que personnellement
sera fait ultra tripes et de faire une
vidéo dans ce genre de me tester dans un
autre style de voir que je pouvais avoir
un truc qui ressemblait un tout petit
peu au moins à sidi pigrée pense que
sous jacent à à ce commentaire et à sa
part aussi dans d'autres commentaires
des vidéos précédentes
il semblerait que j'ai donné
l'impression dans la vidéo précédente
que les convictions c'était forcément
quelque chose de mal ou de pas
souhaitable c'est pas du tout l'objectif
de la vidéo précédente
l'objectif de vidéos précédentes étaient
uniquement descriptif j'ai essayé de
décrire
quelles étaient les conséquences
notamment des nouvelles technologies sur
la manière dont les convictions se
forment se propage se diffuse et je
pense aussi que la diffusion des
sciences et du savoir doit s'adapter à
la manière dont les convictions se
propage
avec internet et je pense pas que ça
soit une mauvaise chose je pense que les
mathématiques sont vivantes
une fois qu'on leur attribue des
émotions moi personnellement j'ai été
atterré par le théorème d'impossibilité
darron gibson wade je suis intrigué par
les ordinateurs quantiques et le fait
qu'ils sont capables de casser la
cryptographie qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
et j'ai été absolument heureux quand
j'ai découvert le scrutin de condorcet
randomisée et c'est pour ça que j'adore
les mathématiques c'est pas parce que ça
rend rationnelle ça aide à réfléchir à
tout ça j'ai envie de dire que c'est un
effet secondaire de side effects du fait
des ronds et mathématiques qui est
souhaitable qui est cool aussi
mais ce n'est pas la raison première
pour laquelle je trouve les
mathématiques fascinante et c'est pas la
raison pour laquelle je passe autant de
temps à lire à penser et si possible
créer des mathématiques
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
manque énormément dans la communication
des sciences en général et des
mathématiques en particulier
c'est cet aspect émotive que c'est
notamment la fascination que les
mathématiques peuvent provoquer parce
que à la réponse comment fait pour
lutter contre les mauvaises conviction
j'ai envie de dire que la seule solution
c'est de développer un esprit critique
et cet esprit critique
il faut vouloir le développer et ça ça
ça communique d'abord par les émotions
à mon sens et absolument pas par un
cours de logique formelle
donc voilà je m'excuse pour ce qu'ils
vont trouver que la vidéo précédente
était trop chargée émotionnellement
notamment négativement et je
réutiliserait pas ça dans toutes les
vidéos à venir
mais comme d'autres ont apprécié je
n'hésiterai pas le réutiliser et d'avoir
ça presque rien à voir mais j'en profite
quand même pour recommander l'une des
meilleures sources de vulgarisation
scientifique à mon sens ce qui est
logique au mix que j'ai déjà replanté
logicomix c'est quand même une bd dans
lequel il travaille quand même pas mal
sur les aspects négatifs émotionnel des
mathématiques et notamment la folie de
pas mal de mathématiciens c'est pas
forcément la valeur qu'on a envie de
mettre en avant quand on parle de
mathématiques
mais c'est peut-être un ressort sur
lequel on peut jouer pour attirer les
gens vers la logique et les amener à
s'intéresser à tout ça tchèque n'aura 68
des nous demandent comment vivre sans
conviction je pense qu objectif c'est
pas de vivre sans conviction et
d'ailleurs je pense qu'une condition
ressemble beaucoup à un virus en ce sens
encore une fois un virus n'est pas bon
ou mauvais et je vous recommande
d'ailleurs au passage l'excellent livre
et zhang haye compte à une multitude je
pense pas qu'ils étaient traduits en
français le choc l'a peut-être que je me
trompe ce bouquin montre que entre corne
à plein plein plein de vieux os et de
bagré que tout c'est bill virus et
bactéries qui ne sont pas vraiment d'où
parce qu'ils sont pas notre adn
en fait son câble pas mal nous parce
qu'ils contrôlent pas mal nos émotions
et nos fêtes notre façon de vivre
du coup virus en particulier sont en
fait indispensables à notre bonne santé
je pense que la même façon les
convictions sont justes incontournable
là où c'est intéressant de voir les
convictions comme des virus c'est de
voir qu'en fait ils ne sont pas vraiment
nous fasse pas vraiment la conviction
que l'on akbou défini et en particulier
ça c'est utile à penser si on veut
commencer à considérer d'autres
convictions faut pas essayer de se
renfermer sur la conviction disons que
ça nous identifient que cc nous quoi
parce que à partir du moment où on s'est
dit moi je suis comme ça passe est très
difficile de changer d'opinion alors que
si on voit les opinions et les
convictions comme des choses qui nous en
fait c'est beaucoup plus facile en leur
sens de se dire bon bah qu'est ce qui se
passe si je prenais cette autre
collection est ce que elle est capable
de survivre à mon esprit est ce que nous
permet de vivre voilà qu'enfin je vole
une idée de 6 degrés dans cette vidéo
mais on voit il faut pas voir les
convictions comme étant quelque chose
qui est mou mais quelque chose qui
infecte nos esprits et dont on peut se
débarrasser potentiellement si on trouve
meilleur conviction
en parlant de ça justement valentin drop
nous demandent comment communiquer nos
convictions
sachant que si on éternue trop
violemment à quelqu'un qui est pas
d'accord avec nous on va le renforcer
dans ses convictions et on va alimenter
plus généralement la conviction
contraire eh bien j'ai envie d'y revenir
aux affaires
c'est de ne pas éternuer violemment sur
le ton de la moquerie notamment des
convictions que l'on a à ceux qui ne
souhaitent pas d'accord avec nous
d'ailleurs j'ai écrit un post de blog en
anglais à suis ta vidéo précédente où je
suggère le fait que john oliver a
favorisé l'élection de trump s'agit pas
de prendre parti pour ou contre train
peint il s'agit vraiment décidé
d'analyser pourquoi est-ce que trump a
été élu parce que je prétends dans ce
post de blog c'est que les blagues très
violente de john oliver ont fait que les
républicains a été très énervé par les
démocrates et et ont donc été renié très
violemment alors toi leurs convictions
ce qui a peut-être conduit à une
popularité de trump bref communiqué ces
conditions vous faire ça bien c'est
super difficile et il faut faire ça
vient et à une très bonne vidéo qui est
il sorti peu près en même temps que la
vidéo précédente qui s'appelle 5 trucs
pour par les haricots noirs et les
conseils qui ont donné dans cette vidéo
pour parler à quelqu'un qui est pro b
quelques l on n'est pas d'accord en fait
ce sont des conseils qui sont très
cohérent avec les découvertes en
psychologie empirique et en sociologie
au pierrick donc je conseille vraiment
cette vidéo je pense que les conseils
sont des bons conseils je pense que le
plus important c'est vraiment d'écouter
et de comprendre ce que les autres
pensent et pourquoi est ce qu'ils
pensent ce qu'ils pensent et c'est
d'aller un peu dans leur sens de de
faire preuve d'empathie pour se lier
émotionnellement avec l'autre et à
partir de ce moment là ce sera plus
facile ensuite après de l'influencé puis
il faut se lit émotionnellement de façon
sincère faut pas juste
prétendre que mais je pense qu'il faut
vraiment faire gaffe à ne pas imposer sa
conviction mais aussi de d'avoir une
conviction qui naissent un petit peu de
notre lien émotionnel avec l'autre
personne d'eaux-vives nous demande quel
est le rapport entre vidéos précédentes
et démocratie démocratie s'est
littéralement le pouvoir au peuple
du coup si on veut savoir si la
démocratie c'est bien aussi si qu'est-ce
que ça produit quelles sont les
conséquences de démocratie qu'est ce
qu'une bonne démocratie et tout ça mais
il me semble qu'il est indispensable de
comprendre ce que le peuple veut et
pourquoi est ce qu'il veut ce qu'il veut
et donc le modèle de diffusion des
convictions qu'on a vu dans l'épisode
précédent répond à cette question
joseph barthélémy marque devant quel est
le lien avec les mathématiques et ça je
trouve ça trop cool on me reproche de
pas assez parlé de mathématiques je veux
dire toute ma vie c est l inverse la
halle à des gens qui veulent que je
parle de plus de mathématiques et bien
il faut savoir qu'il ya énormément de
mathématiques qui tourne autour de ces
questions de propagation de
l'information des convictions
en général quand on perd il ya beaucoup
de recherches sur comment la structure
du réseau influence la manière dont les
informations se propage et ça ça a
énormément énormément d'applications ont
déjà dans tout ce qui est réseau que
l'on construit donc par exemple si on
construit une architecture de calcul
chignon google et construire un nouveau
data centers
comment est ce qu'on le lit et aux
autres questions et bande passante à
mettre entre différents data center à
tous genres tout ça ce sont les modèles
qui sont très liés à la diffusion de
l'information
une autre application quel on pense pas
forcément
c'est ce qu'on appelle le cascades fire
qui est le fait que si on a un réseau
électrique
si un câble pète alors tout électricité
qui passait à travers ce câble va devoir
être redirigé par d'autres câbles qui
peuvent alors être en hypertension et
qui peuvent péter à leur tour ce qui va
augmenter et augmenter le problème du
coup le fait qu'un câble pète on peut
voir ça comme une information et de
l'information se diffuse à travers le
réseau est encore la structure du réseau
influence grandement de manière dont ce
pétage de câble se propage à travers le
réseau est d'ailleurs un des gros
problèmes de mathématiques que je trouve
fascinant et je ne connais absolument
pas répond c'est à ma connaissance
encore un problème qui est très très
très ouvert et c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de recharge
c'est comment décrire les réseaux en
général
intitulé les réseaux électriques ou les
réseaux sociaux c'est la manière dont
les personnes sont liées les unes aux
autres ou les réseaux internet ou les
réseaux web
aujourd'hui on a un modèle très basique
pour décrire ces réseaux qui est le
modèle garde au chaud
rennie mais ce modèle on sait qu'il
n'est pas le bon modèle dans la plupart
des réseaux et du coup c'est trouver un
modèle pour décrire efficacement les
réseaux sociaux électrique ou autre ça
ça serait un modèle très très très très
intéressant et pendant ce temps on ne
l'a pas tout cas pas ma connaissance
elle j'espère que vous avez aimé cet
épisode je vous conseille très très très
très très vivement de lire aux buneaux
de m'excuser parce que les explications
que j'ai donné ici c'est très très très
très incomplète si vous voulez vraiment
comprendre la politique vie insiste
vraiment d'issue disait mesquita donc de
mesquita moi j'ai lu deux prédictions et
un scream qui est ce qu'il a écrit tout
seul
il ya aussi co écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelle des 10-14 and book
j'ai vu nos productions du mal
heureusement j'arrive pas à l'acheter
sur téléphone ou sur audi bol j'ai pas
pu lire des dictateurs handbook il ya
l'excellente vidéo de sidi pigray qui
reprend tony de facebook que je
conseille très très très très vivement
et j'ai aussi lu ce bouquin de pozuelo
de nesquik par un petit peu plus des
mathématiques les mathématiques en fait
ce n'est pas très sophistiqué
là où le modèle de mesquita est très
intéressant c'est parce qu'il a des très
bons résultats surtout pour quoi qu'il
en soit le livre plus académique que
j'ai lu été coécrit avec trois autres
auteurs s'appelle de logic of political
survival et je vous recommande encore
une fois très très très vivement de vous
plonger dans cette façon de penser la
politique qui a juste changé
on a posé clic et je pense qu'elle m'a
permis de bien mieux comprendre ce qui
se passe vraiment dans le monde de la
politique et je conseille au passage la
série télévisée haus of corse
j'ai l'impression que mes skis et a été
conseiller scientifique sur cette série
parce que cette série est une superbe
illustration des idées de mesquita vaut
vraiment un personnage qui réagit aux
incentives et dont le but est d'être et
de rester au pouvoir
si vous voulez vraiment comprendre toute
la logique de décider à y penser selon
la logique du modèle domestique
moi je voudrais vraiment l'avoir à
sauvegarde très bonne initiation à cette
théorie qu'au coeur de la théorie de
mesquita il ya bien sûr le concept d'
incentives accueille un concert ultra
ultra ultra important et on reviendra
dessus dans le prochain épisode c'est
vraiment le concept le plus important de
toute la théorie des jeux
vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à la
ligue et à le commentaire et le partage
et pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes merci at il
peur pour leurs dons et j'espère que
vous serez là la prochaine fois mais on
trouve très rapidement une utilité un
truc qui a partout au congo le
caoutchouc
mais à partir de là c'est la folie de
l'or qui collent des blues